I have the most absolutely exciting news to share
that I wanna share with all of my TikTok friends
because these opportunities would not have come to me
if it weren't for you. I am writing a motherfucking book.
Like, a real book.
Not like, I'm not just, like,
on my own, self publishing something like
there I have a team and it's gonna be published with, like,
a real publisher, and we're working on it,
and it is outrageously exciting.
And I have, like, other, like,
little projects that I'm working on
and fucking flying to Los Angeles tomorrow to film something.
So I'm, like,
outrageously thankful for the support.
I know there's plenty of hate and that could just.
I'm just choosing to ignore all that
because the opportunities that are coming my way are just, like,
literal dreams. And I'm so thankful for all of my friends here
that have loved and supported me through my little healing process
to get from Chad wife to, like,
single mom standing on my own.
Fucking add author to the list.
So I just wanted to share that super exciting news
with my little TikTok family.
I love you guys so fucking much.
And if you're in a fucking marriage that you're not happy with,
I guarantee you're not crazy,
and I guarantee you'd be a lot happier if you laughed.